est liée à l'idée latente
qu'en séparant le sexe de la reproduction, nous allons promouvoir la promiscuité.
C'est en effet une question importante :
quel est l'impact de la contraception sur la morale sexuelle ?
Comme de nombreuses autres femmes,
ma décision sur le contrôle de ma fertilité est indépendante de ça.
J'ai planifié mon avenir. Je voulais aller à l'université.
J'ai étudié dur à la fac,
et j'étais très fière de faire partie des rares femmes de mon université
diplômée en informatique.
Je voulais faire carrière.
Je me suis donc inscrite dans une école de commerce.
pour devenir ensuite une des plus jeunes directrices chez Microsoft.
Je me souviens du message de mes parents quand j'ai quitté la maison,
pour déménager à l'autre bout du pays, et travailler chez Microsoft.
Ils avaient fait beaucoup de sacrifices pour me permettre d'aller à la fac.
Mais ils ont dit ceci,
alors que je descendais les marches devant la maison :
ils m'ont dit :
« Même si tu as reçu cette formation universitaire,
si tu décides de te marier, d'avoir des enfants immédiatement,
c'est OK ! »
Ils voulaient que je fasse les choix qui me rendent heureuse.
J'étais libre de décider de ces choix.
Ce sentiment était extraordinaire.
En fait, je voulais avoir des enfants,
mais je les voulais en étant prête à les accueillir.
Avec Bill, nous en avons trois.
Quand notre aînée est née,
nous ne savions pas comment être des parents formidables.
Certains d'entre vous me comprennent sûrement.
On a donc attendu un peu avant d'avoir le deuxième.
Ce n'est pas un hasard,
si nos trois enfants ont chacun trois ans de différence.
En tant que maman, quel est mon souhait le plus cher pour mes enfants ?
Je souhaite qu'ils ressentent ce que j'ai ressenti.
Ce sentiment de pouvoir faire tout ce qu'ils veulent dans leur vie.
J'ai pu constater maintes fois
durant mes voyages pour la fondation ces dernières décennies,
que toutes les femmes dans le monde souhaitent la même chose.
L'année dernière, à Nairobi, j'ai visité des bidonvilles,
dont un qui s'appelle Korogocho, qui se traduit littéralement
par « vivre épaule contre épaule ».
J'ai parlé avec ces femmes sur cette photo.
Elles parlaient très ouvertement
de leur vie de famille dans les bidonvilles.
Elles ont parlé aussi des moyens
qu'elles utilisaient pour contrôler leur fertilité.
Marianne, qui est au centre du groupe, avec un pull rouge,
a très bien résumé notre conversation de deux heures
en une phrase que je n'oublierai jamais :
« Je veux faire don à cet enfant de toutes les bonnes choses de la vie
avant d'en avoir un autre. »
J'ai pensé que c'était exactement ça !
C'est un sentiment universel.
Nous souhaitons toutes donner le meilleur à nos enfants.
Mais ce qui n'est pas universel, c'est notre capacité à réaliser ce vœu.
Tant de femmes souffrent de violence domestique.
Elles ne rêvent même pas de discuter de contraception,
même en privé, avec leur mari.
Tant de femmes n'ont pas reçu d'éducation là-dessus.
Même les femmes qui ont reçu cette éducation et qui en ont le pouvoir,
n'ont pas accès à la contraception.
Pendant 250 ans, les parents du monde
ont décidé de fonder des familles plus petites.
Cette tendance est stable depuis un quart de millénaire,
quelques soient les cultures et les pays,
à la seule exception flagrante
de l’Afrique sub-saharienne et de l’Asie du Sud.
En France, les familles ont commencé à devenir plus petites,
dès la moitié du 18ème siècle.
Et durant les 150 ans suivants,
cette tendance s’est élargie à toute l’Europe .
J’ai été très surprise d’apprendre
que cette évolution n’a pas suivi les frontières socio-économiques,
mais s'est répandue à travers les communautés culturelles.
Les personnes qui partageaient une langue commune
ont fait ce choix en tant que groupe.
Ils ont opté pour ce choix familial, qu’ils soient riches ou pauvres.
La raison de l'expansion des familles plus petites
est fondée sur un principe :
l'idée que les couples peuvent exercer un contrôle conscient
sur le nombre d’enfants qu’ils ont.
C’est un concept très fort.
Ça signifie que les parents peuvent avoir une influence sur l'avenir,
et non plus le subir.
En France, la taille de la famille moyenne a diminué chaque décennie
pendant 150 ans, jusqu’à se stabiliser.
Ça a pris autant de temps
parce que les moyens de contraception n’étaient pas aussi efficaces.
En Allemagne, la transition a débuté dans les années 1880.
En 50 ans, la taille des familles s’est stabilisée.
En Asie et en Amérique latine, la transition a débuté dans les années 60.
Le processus fut encore plus rapide,
grâce aux moyens de contraception modernes.
Je pense que l’histoire nous donne un éclairage important,
pour nous permettre de réfléchir sereinement,
et nous souvenir des raisons qui ont créé la polémique autour de ce thème.
C’est parce que certains programmes de planning familial
ont eu la mauvaise idée de recourir à des programmes incitatifs ou coercitifs.
Par exemple, dans les années 60, l’Inde a adopté des objectifs chiffrés
et offrait une rémunération aux femmes qui acceptaient l’implant d’un stérilet.
Les femmes Indiennes n’étaient pas nées de la dernière pluie.
Au moment de l’implantation, elles recevaient 6 roupies.
Alors, qu’ont-elles fait ?
Après quelques heures, ou quelques jours,
elles se rendaient dans une autre officine,
et y demandaient le retrait de l’implant, pour une roupie.
Pendant des années, aux Etats-Unis,
on a stérilisé des femmes afro-américaines sans leur consentement.
La procédure était si banale,
qu’elle était connue sous le nom d’appendicectomie du Mississipi.
Une page tragique dans l’histoire de mon pays.
Il n’y a pas si longtemps, dans les années 90, au Pérou,
on anesthésiait les femmes dans les Andes
et les stériliser à leur insu.
Le plus surprenant dans cette histoire,
c'est que ces méthodes coercitives n'étaient pas nécessaires.
Elles avaient lieu dans des régions
où les parents souhaitaient déjà avoir des familles plus petites.
Parce que, région après région, encore et encore,
les parents souhaitaient fonder des familles plus petites.
Il n'y a aucune raison de croire
que les femmes africaines souhaitent quelque chose de différent.
Si elles en ont le choix, elles auront moins d'enfants.
La question est donc la suivante :
allons-nous investir pour permettre
à toutes les femmes d'obtenir ce qu'elles veulent ?
Ou allons-nous les condamner à combattre une guerre des siècles passés,
comme un retour à l'époque de la révolution française,
lorsque la méthode la plus sûre était le coït interrompu.
Aucune justification n'est nécessaire pour offrir l'autonomie aux parents.
Le point central est que
notre désir de faire don du meilleur à nos enfants
est une force positive dans le monde entier.
C'est une force qui propulse les sociétés vers l'avenir.
Dans ce bidonville de Nairobi, j'ai rencontré une jeune femme d'affaires.
Elle cousait des sacs à dos à la maison.
Avec ses jeunes enfants, elle se rendait à l'usine de jeans locale,
et ramassait les chutes de tissus,
pour fabriquer ces sacs à dos, et les vendre.
Quand je l'ai rencontrée, elle avait trois enfants.
Nous avons parlé de sa famille.
Elle m'a dit qu'avec son mari, ils avaient décidé
de ne plus avoir d'enfants après leur troisième.
Je lui ai demandé pourquoi. Voici ce qu'elle a répondu :
« Je ne pourrai plus gérer mon entreprise si j'ai un autre enfant. »
Elle m'a expliqué que les revenus générés par son entreprise
lui permettaient d'offrir une éducation à ses trois enfants.
Elle était incroyablement optimiste pour l'avenir de sa famille.
Elle a réalisé le même calcul mental
que des centaines de milliers d'hommes et de femmes.
Les faits montrent qu'ils ont raison.
Ils peuvent offrir à leurs enfants davantage d'opportunités,
en gérant le moment de leur naissance.
Au Bangladesh, il y a un quartier appelé Matlab.
Des chercheurs y ont collecté des données sur 180 000 habitants depuis 1963.
Dans la communauté mondiale de la santé, on aime penser qu'il s'agit
d'une des plus longues recherches jamais effectuées
Elle génère d'incroyables statistiques.
Dans une des études,
la moitié des villageois a reçu des moyens de contraception.
On les a formés et on leur a donné accès aux méthodes.
20 ans plus tard, nous avons constaté
que ces villageois avaient une meilleure qualité de vie que leurs voisins.
Les familles étaient en meilleure santé.
Les femmes avaient moins de risques de mourir en couche.
Les enfants étaient moins susceptibles de mourir
durant leur premier mois.
Les enfants étaient mieux nourris.
Les familles étaient aussi plus riches.
Le salaire moyen des femmes était plus élevé.
Les familles avaient davantage de biens : du bétail, des terrains ou des économies.
Leurs fils et leurs filles recevaient une meilleure éducation.
En multipliant ces effets par les millions de familles,
le résultat est un développement économique à grande échelle.
On parle souvent du miracle économique en Asie dans les années 80.
Mais ce n'était pas exactement un miracle.
Une des raisons de la croissance économique dans cette région
est la tendance culturelle en faveur de famille plus petite.
Les changements fondamentaux sont initiés au niveau individuel de la famille.
Une famille décide ce qui est le mieux pour ses enfants.
Quand elle initie ce changement, et prend une telle décision,
cela engendre une tendance généralisée, régionale et nationale.
Quand les familles en Afrique sub-sahariennes ont la possibilité
de prendre ces décisions par elles-mêmes,
je suis persuadée que ça créera un cercle vertueux
de développement de ces communautés sur tout le continent.
Nous pouvons aider les familles pauvres à construire un avenir meilleur.
Nous pouvons insister sur l'importance
d'offrir la chance à tous de connaître les méthodes contraceptives,
et d'y avoir accès, quelque soit la méthode.
L'objectif est très clair :
l'accès universel aux méthodes de contraception
que les femmes souhaitent utiliser.
Et pour y parvenir, tous les gouvernements,
qu'ils soient riches ou pauvres,
doivent faire de la contraception leur priorité absolue.
Chacun d'entre nous dans cette pièce peut agir mondialement,
en devenant le porte-parle des centaines de millions de familles
qui n'ont pas encore accès aux moyens de contraception,
et en expliquant combien ça pourrait améliorer leur vie.
Si Marianne et les membres de son groupe peuvent parler de ce sujet ouvertement,
et en discuter entre elles et en public,
nous pouvons aussi en parler.
Nous devons commencer maintenant.
Parce que, nous aussi, comme Marianne,
nous souhaitons tous le meilleur pour nos enfants.
Où y a-t-il matière à controverse ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson : Merci.
J'ai quelques questions pour Melinda.
Merci pour votre courage et pour tous vos accomplissements.
Melinda, ces dernières années,
de nombreuses voix se sont levées pour dire
que nous n'avons plus besoin de nous soucier
de la croissance démographique.
La taille des familles se réduit naturellement partout dans le monde.
Nous atteindrons un plafond vers 9 ou 10 milliards de personnes.
Ces voix ont-elles tort ?
MG : Les statistiques en Afrique leur donnent tort.
Nous devons approcher le problème sous un autre angle.
Nous devons le regarder du bas vers le haut.
C'est pour ça que la contraception cause tant de polémique.
On y réfléchit du haut vers le bas, en décrétant que nous souhaitons
modifier la démographie.
Bien-sûr, nous nous préoccupons de la planète,
et nous devons prendre les bonnes décisions.
Mais ces choix doivent être pris par les familles.
Ce n'est que quand on permet aux gens de choisir ce qu'ils souhaitent
que l'on obtient ces changements fondamentaux que nous voyons partout,
sauf en Afrique sub-saharienne, en Asie du Sud et en Afghanistan.
CA : Certaines personnes très à droite en Amérique
et dans de nombreuses cultures conservatrices dans le monde,
pourraient dire ceci :
« Tout ça c'est très bien, l'autonomie des femmes, sauver des vies...
mais le sexe est quelque chose de sacré.
Ce que vous proposez ne fera qu'augmenter la probabilité des relations hors mariage.
C'est répréhensible. »
Que leur répondez-vous ?
MG : Je suis d'accord, le sexe est quelque chose de sacré.
C'est sacré en Allemagne, aux Etats-Unis,
en France, et dans beaucoup d'endroits dans le monde.
Le fait que 98% des femmes de mon pays qui ont déjà eu une expérience sexuelle,
affirment gérer leur fertilité, ne rend pas le sexe moins sacré.
Ça signifie simplement qu'elles peuvent faire des choix sur leur vie.
Je crois que ce choix-là,
fait honneur au caractère sacré de la famille, de la vie des mamans,
de la vie de leurs enfants, en sauvant leur vie.
A mes yeux, c'est tout aussi sacré.
CA : Quelles actions sont mises en place par votre fondation ?
Que peut faire chaque personne dans la salle ou sur internet ?
Quel est votre message ?
MG : J'aimerais que tout le monde prenne part à la discussion.
Voici l'adresse web. Rejoignez-nous.
Racontez-nous comment la contraception a influencé votre vie,
ou celle de vos proches.
Affirmez votre position.
Nous avons besoin de vous, pour en affirmer le bien-fondé,
pour donner l'accès à la contraception à toutes les femmes, dans le monde entier.
Une de nos prochaines actions aura lieu à Londres le 11 juillet prochain.
Avec de nombreux pays, de nombreux pays d'Afrique aussi,
nous allons remettre ce sujet dans les programmes de santé mondiaux.
Nous allons engager des ressources.
Nous allons planifier avec les gouvernements
des actions au niveau des familles qui garantissent une formation des femmes.
Si elles le souhaitent, elles pourront obtenir les moyens,
et choisir parmi plusieurs options,
en se rendant dans leur centre médical local.
CA : Melinda, j'imagine que les sœurs qui vous ont enseignée au lycée
vont probablement écouter votre présentation.
Seront-elles horrifiées ou vont-elles vous encourager ?
MG: Je sais qu'elles vont écouter la présentation,
parce qu'elles sont au courant et que je vais la leur envoyer.
Les sœurs qui m'ont éduquée sont incroyablement progressistes.
J'espère qu'elles seront fières de moi,
en m'observant vivre selon leurs préceptes de justice sociale et de service.
Ce sujet me passionne profondément.
J'ai vu tant de choses dans le monde en voie de développement,
j'ai rencontré tant de femmes sans voix,
que ce sujet occupe toutes mes pensées et mon cœur.
Ces femmes ne peuvent pas rester sans voix.
Leur voix doit compter. Elles doivent avoir le choix.
J'espère que les sœurs comprendront
que j'applique ce que j'ai appris d'elles
et de toutes ces années d'actions au sein de la fondation.
CA : Avec votre équipe, vous avez réuni des orateurs de talent.
Merci beaucoup.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez appris aujourd'hui ?
(Rires)
MG : J'ai appris tant de choses. J'ai l'esprit plein de questions.
J'envisage ce travail comme un voyage.
Nous avons écouté une présentation d'un voyage à travers l'énergie,
d'un voyage au sein de l'architecture sociale,
d'un voyage vers la maturité qui demande :
« Pourquoi si peu de femmes sur cette scène ? »
Je suis convaincue que nous tous qui travaillons pour le développement,
on apprend en parlant aux gens.
On apprend sur le tas, en essayant et en nous trompant.
Parfois ce sont les questions que l'on pose qui nous mènent à la réponse
la prochaine personne qui nous aidera à trouver la réponse.
J'ai beaucoup de questions pour les orateurs.
J'ai passé une journée fantastique.
CA : Melinda, merci pour votre invitation à vous accompagner dans votre voyage.
Merci beaucoup. MG : Merci, Chris.